deck Collinsworth and Rodney
Harrison who witnessed it and
are joined by a very special
guest. My goodness guys. This
was incredible. What a gunshot?
See a good Chris Josh Jacobs
and soon as that final kick left
the tone. I saw three
Raiders fans in the front row in
a tier
left there.
What the hell did we just watch
tonight? I mean man. This has
been a long time coming for the
for our fans man. A lot of ups
and downs and I met, we mark
this on our calendar at
the beginning of the year.
We know that the job's not done,
but we just happy to get here.
You guys overcame so much this
year.
What does it say about this
team?
And I think it speaks to the
guys, man. I think it speaks to
the coaches. I think it speaks
to the whole organization in
general.
I mean, with all the outside
noise, the guy's just always
put our head down and we locked
in and we believed in each
other and we believed in the
goal that we had at
the beginning of the year and
we still trying to ground
towards their
Josh. What's it feel? Like when
it's late, fourth quarter over
time, you feel that defense
starting to wear down and now
you get to go. Drop the hammer
on them from your perspective.
And I told the guys on the side.
Windows for a minute before all
the time. I said, man, I'm
a closer. I'm in as a running
back. I feel like that's one of
the most important things or
important aspects you can have.
And I'm so I told Coach movie
went over time. I said, man
allowed me to be who I am,
and he believed that allowed me
to do it and we went out there
and then we, we borrow the thing
that impressed me is, I'm
watching you on tape, and I know
that you're not 100% and
you come out here, guys, I
hitting you banging, you,
and you continue to run just run
hard.
I mean, man, this is I think
it's a mentality.
I told him now, they was, there
was
Debating on it. If I was gonna
play this game tonight,
I said, man is no way. I would
sit out for these. I don't care
if I was,
you had to pull me out. This
game is for me to sit out, man,
with everything else on the
line, and everything, nose and
steak. And I mean, that's the
type of mentality that I have.
I mean, just coming out and
wanted to work on wanting
the best
for the team. I got to ask you
about Max Crosby
because Max, just completely
took over the game.
What is he like in practice?
It's crazy because you see the
same thing. He'd why he's like
that every day. I mean, the high
motor very skillful long,
as y'all,
he's that
So we come out here, he do it.
It's like you almost expected
from
a, I mean, that's a testament to
him, and he's a great
player. He's got, he's becoming
a superstar. I mean, I'm most
happy for me. We came in
together.
We all have made an agreement.
Our whole
draft class made an agreement
that we was gonna be the one
that's helped change his
franchise. Help change this
culture and family back. The
impact that he is, is
definitely huge.
What are the trip to the
playoffs represent the coach
besides Chia and this entire
Raider organization, man, cause
massage and everybody loves
them. I'm he's one of them guys
that. You go to him and bad
times. We have stuff going on
in your life.
He's one of them type of dudes,
man. And
I feel like, if you have a coach
like that, you always
play harder for him. You always
listen, you always do extra.
You aren't doing a little bit
more each day. And now he has
an ultimate respect from the
guys in the locker room.
Why do you think he's the right
guy to lead you guys forward
after this game? I think because
he knows what it is to
be on every level. He knows what
it is. Just be there for
the guys.
And now do you stepping into
that lead room?
He knows how to be a leader
and he had he already has the
Attention of the room.
And guys were expecting. So
whatever he asked people to do.
They're going to do a lot of
people focus on offense and
defense, but I was telling Jack
that in,
you know, in pregame that
special teams are so important
to you guys. You guys have two
awesome kickers that really
helped you out this game, man.
It's crazy. Just way if you
ever look at me on the sidelines
when we kick in any
type of field
on my hands already up,
I call him I call a sniper
Daniel, Carson. I know what
he's gonna do AJ Khomeini answer
crazy leg. I know what
he's going to do is it's great
to have God's, you know, Know
what they're going to do? Is
they do you know what? They
were going to get out of them. I
mean, it's a high respect
level for me. Alright early
looking to the Cincinnati
Bengals. What do you think
about?
I think they're a good team. I
think that they jailed at
the right time off, instantly.
They going crazy defensively.
They're going crazy. I think
it's going to be a great
matchup man. I can't wait to get
getting the lab and study
some film on them and
try to come out and play. Josh.
I want to ask you about their
car because I was watching him
warm up. If you could just tell
there was something different
about this game, what it meant
to him, what it meant to his
career. How is pairing with
Are impacted your career, man. I
told him, I said, man, coming
into this game. I said it's
going to come down to me. You
said we want one of us will have
to make a play
and I told him, I said, man,
you owe yourself is, I'll see
the work that he put in every
day
when he doing. He don't want to
talk me
how to read things on his
offensive like quarterback. I'm
out there. I'll make the station
calls and things like
that because he taught me that
and I mean, this is a big
Testament to who he is. He's a
great guy on and off the field,
but we wish
you nothing. But the best, man,
great game.
We appreciate you coming
through, bro.
I
will see you next week.